let's now take some phone calls we're
going to hear from people in the
audience we do this via Discord they're
not really phone calls but sometimes
it's kind of like hard to explain what
they are if I don't say phone calls so I
just call them phone calls but you go to
davidpackman.com
Discord and uh that's where it's all
happening all right let's go with Adrian
from Wyoming and hear from Adrian first
today Adrian what's going on
hi David I have a question for you about
um what Joe Biden cares about because I
know there's kind of a maxim about if
presidents really care about certain
issues they'll do more and I'm wondering
how you think he's done regarding trans
rights especially in the wake of uh the
potential expulsion of a Montana state
senator today I don't know exactly
what's going on with that I did not see
that story but let me address that you
know here's here's the thing with all of
these issues so often this debate starts
about has the president done enough or
not on a particular issue and then
subsequent to that the question becomes
how much can a president do about that
particular issue and when it comes to
trans issues the unfortunate reality is
that a lot of this stuff is determined
at the state level now you could say
well there should be some overarching
federal law protecting trans people but
we already know from experience with
other issues related to gender and
sexual orientation that that often is
not something that it happens or happens
quickly so I I have to admit I don't
know the full scope of what Biden could
do federally to best evaluate how what
kind of a job he's done if that makes
sense
right and I personally like I'm I'm
right with you there I realized that in
a deadlock Congress there's very little
that's potentially going to get done
especially with the red meat that this
issue unfortunately provides the
Republican base absolutely um I just
think I just wander and uh just wanted
to hear your perspective uh symbolically
like like for when he invited the
Tennessee three over earlier I believe
this week
um and just hosting more events or just
talking a little bit more about those
kind of issues just from that kind of
perspective because I realized
legislatively that he's kind of
deadlocked and not much may get done but
I appreciate your thoughts on well
listen I mean okay so Biden could sign
executive orders and and Direct Federal
departments to uh enact certain policy
protections okay so I don't know that
he's done a ton of that he can use the
bully pulpit to talk about the issue I
think he has I mean he brings up Tran
issues at many speeches so I think there
he's doing okay he can appoint officials
in his administration who are Defenders
of trans rights and I think mostly he's
done that he certainly hasn't appointed
anyone I'm aware of who's hostile or
indifferent to trans right so that's
okay
um and then he can sort of like push
state and local governments to do one
thing or the other but the unfortunate
reality is the state the state
governments that would listen to Biden
are already doing pretty well when it
comes to protecting trans people anyway
and the state governments that are
aggressively persecuting trans people
aren't going to care what Joe Biden says
anyway so you know I think he's doing
okay but he could always do more
yeah I fully agree I am I really
appreciate it um because I know that uh
my ex home my ex state where I went to
college in Minnesota there they took a
big step back everyone's either taking
big steps up or big steps back and it's
just very unfortunate to see right now
so I appreciate you taking the call
thanks for your perspective hope you
have a great day all right thank you
there is Adrian from Wyoming let's go
next to genio from Chester is this
Chester Springs yes genio from Chester
Springs welcome to the program what's on
your mind today
hi can you hear me yes I can
hi uh Chester Springs Pennsylvania
outside of Philadelphia love it that's
awesome
um I'm surprised I got picked um thank
you um so my question is my first
question is I've always wanted to ask
you a big fan for a long time do you
listen to Howard Stern you know I've
I've been a listener since I was like
age 14 but if I'm totally honest since
the pandemic started I've barely
listened at all
I mean part of it is I I no longer have
serious radio so I know that a bunch of
the like the interviews get posted to
YouTube or whatnot but I don't have
Sirius anymore
I understand I understand well Howard
does wonderful interviews just like you
do that's why I asked because
I feel like he's one of the best
interviewers and his interviews have
gotten better over the past few years I
agree um and I find that you are a
wonderful interviewer as well so I
thought maybe you had some inspiration I
agree that he's a great interviewer and
I appreciate the compliment but I I have
not had the pleasure of listening much
lately now let me ask you this for a
while he was like down in his house in
Florida doing the show remotely is he
back in the New York Studio
you know what I think he's still
um he's still fully remote he's very
very anxious about kovid and he's like
just getting at like he talks about it
almost on a daily basis he's just
getting out and like meeting friends and
he's still like very worried about it
and um but I I could be wrong but I
think he's still in his studio in the
Hamptons and his studio in Florida got
it fair he is but yeah I think he's
remote still but he has like he's had
some really good interviews and that
they um when he has musical guests they
go to the serious studio in New York I
believe all right very good well let's
uh let let me not to take time away from
your question
I have one other question
um how do you feel about
um and I might have missed it here and
there about your feelings on Israel and
the Israeli government because as a you
know a Jewish American and I want to
support Israel but I have really hard
feeling I have a hard time supporting
Israel knowing some of the things that
they're doing to Palestinians and I just
wanted to know like what your feelings
on that is I have certainly dozens of
clips about this I mean my view is that
I am a hundred percent opposed to these
right-wing Israeli governments Netanyahu
Etc I'm against illegal settlements I
would like to see the blockade with Gaza
ended and I also recognize that it's
simply not going to end until there are
either certain concessions or assurances
that come from Hamas which is
extraordinarily unlikely and it's it's
such a complicated issue genio but I
think I'm often attacked as being a
shill for Israel and a lot of that is
unfortunately just because I'm Jewish
and it's disappointing to see that when
it comes to policy
if you look at I've probably done it 10
times now if you look at my policy idea
for how to resolve the conflict I think
it's it's quite fair and both sides
could probably find issue with it but I
think there's one other important thing
one of the things that's unfortunate is
there's a standard applied to Israel
when it comes to quote supporting the
country which might include like even
going on a trip that no one applies to
other countries which I would like to
see change like for example if people
very few people see like for example I
went to England when Boris Johnson was
the Prime Minister I didn't support
Boris Johnson but to say I won't go
there because it's an endorsement of
Johnson I don't agree with that and yet
like when I went to Israel people wrote
to me saying how could you you're
supporting settlements you're supporting
Netanyahu because you're there that is
like never really applied to other
countries and I would like to see that
applied a little more fairly people came
to the U.S when Trump was President
didn't mean they supported Trump you
know what I'm saying yeah for sure no I
completely agree with you yeah and I
also feel like people because I I you
know we're Jewish people feel like we
have to support Israel and I support
Israel as a country and I support the
people who live there but I don't
support the government just how people
would support the United States but they
not that wouldn't necessarily support
Trump and I'll go further than that
Jenny I'll go even further not only do
Jews not have to do anything in
particular when it comes to supporting
or defending or attacking Israel
um American Jews also have no reason to
even be answering the questions about
Israeli foreign policy I was once at a
brunch a couple years ago and met
someone for the first time and they
started putting me in the position of
having to explain to them about this
that or the other thing about Israel and
it's like I've been there once in my
life I'm from Argentina I've lived in
the United States the vast majority of
my life I happen to be Jewish but it's
it's kind of weird to put me in a
position of having to defend or explain
anything about Israel ask Israelis you
know yeah that's so so true thank you so
much I really appreciate your response
all right Jenny O from Chester Springs
beautifully asked